el acuerdo entre el fondo
monetariointernacional y argentina quedó
finalmente sellado con el objetivo de
refinanciar una deuda de 44 mil millones
de dólares y evitar el cese de pagos
argentinas ahora podrá hacer frente a
sus obligaciones durante al menos 30
meses en un contexto global de
incertidumbre derivado de la pandemia de
conflictos bélicos logramos este acuerdo
que nos permite visualizar un horizonte
de crecimiento la comunidad
internacional nos ha acompañado
argentina y el fondo monetario
internacional han tenido una larga y
complicada relación en 1958 dos años
después de que el país ingresará al
organismo se firmó el primer acuerdo por
75 millones de dólares desde entonces ha
adquirido 29 préstamos históricamente
para cumplir con los pagos los gobiernos
han tenido que llevar a cabo recortes en
planes sociales algo que ha despertado
la ira que ha sido expresada en
multitudinarias protestas pese a que la
recuperación económica y el empleo están
en marcha argentinas sigue afrontando
retos excepcionales económicos y
sociales como un ingreso per cápita
deprimido niveles elevados de pobreza
una inflación persistente una carga
pesada de deuda y amortiguadores
externos bajos la junta del organismo
internacional permitirá un desembolso
inmediato de 9.600 millones de dólares
el dinero restante que necesita el país
sudamericano será entregado entre 2026 y
2.034 algo que entre otras medidas
obligaría a argentina a reducir los
subsidios energéticos y a aumentar la
recaudación impositiva